s'ils ont regardé bien la france du
général de gaulle aujourd'hui on dirait
que tu démocratie autoritaire
on dirait que c'est une démocrature et
je me demande si on regarderait pas le
général de gaulle commande attend ça
regardez vous admire poutine s'était un
peu de tout le régime du général de
gaulle c'est aussi une démocratie parce
que les oppositions vivait alors elle
passait pas par la télévision à la radio
et avait beaucoup de journaux il y avait
une opinion publique vivant en france
dans les années 50 et 60
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit le cas en
russie je ne pense pas que le pouvoir
laisse vivre l'opinion publique de
gaulle laisser vivre l'opinion publique
mais il maîtrisait la télé la radio et
je pense qu'avec un peu plus
d'investigations je me souviens
notamment de l'affairé ben barka où le
pouvoir gaulliste a été très bousculés
par les journaux de presse écrite très
bousculée ben barka opposant marocain
qui est assassiné à paris en 1966 donc
on ne peut pas tout à fait faire le
parallèle mais c'est vrai que ça n'était
pas une démocratie parfaite et que le
général on a tendance à l'oublier a eu
longtemps avec la république et la
démocratie une relation très distantes
l'obsession du général c'est qu'il y ait
un chef à la tête de l'état après quelle
forme ça prend il a longtemps hésité il
s'est converti à la démocratie en disant
notamment dans les années cinquante à
ses proches que la dictature c'était
bien au début mais après ça tournait
toujours mal les dictatures ne s'était
pas ce n'est pas un rejet de principe
c'était plutôt une analyse intelligente
de ce qu'est une situation d'inconfort
ou de confort donc on ne peut pas dire
que c'était les principes qui guident
est de ce point de vue la réflexion du
général de gaulle donc on peut le
regarder sans doute aujourd'hui avec un
oeil critique
il était plus démocrate que dictateur
quand même
je crois
[Musique]